I would vote for thon oohs before I
would vote for any of these people
really unfurl the lunacy of leftism
really easily because you know if if
they had a consistent set of views so
you can say what you want about the
right but the right basically and
certainly in this room what is the right
care about the individual that if that
every single one of us should have
individual rights that are exactly the
same regardless of the color of your
skin or your gender or any of those
things I can't look at any I mean think
how depressingly twisted it would be if
I looked at any of you and I was like oh
she's black so she must think this or or
he's gay so he must think this or
something like that but yet that is what
the left is doing and that's that's so
ironic right now because if if you
really believe as so many of the
progressives do that that Trump is
Hitler and evil and all of those things
well the answer isn't it's just to get
our guy to be in that position of power
the answer is let's take the power away
from that office which is how it was
supposed to be set up in the first part
[Applause]
so if you were a betting man you'd put
your mom oh so I didn't answer the
question how about that I'm trying to
vote for you guys you just talk long
enough so that they forget what the
question was Obama used to do that all
the time do you remember the Obama press
conference is that way they would be
like mr. president you know what's the
temperature outside like six hours later
like it was okay if I was a betting
person I think it's probably gonna be
Elizabeth Warren I almost see sort of no
yeah but but I could say anything you'd
boo any of them might be there they're
all terrible they're horrible I mean
even did you watch this climate change
summit the amount of lunacy Bertie was
literally demanding that we offer free
abortions to people in South America to
stop climate change I mean that's how
I'm not making that up I am NOT making
that up we used to there used to be some
American program where we would offer
abortion services in other countries
which what does that have to do with
shouldn't we be doing things in our
country or forget abortion specifically
but he literally was bringing that up
that if we don't reenact this policy
that that you know populate I mean he
wants these dados
basically I would vote for tan O's
before I would vote for any of these
people but so I think I think I think
Elizabeth Warren probably I think the
most beautiful part of watching it all
unfold will be the way that they have to
destroy Bernie because Bernie he has to
be destroyed he's an old white man at
the end and at the end that is that is
how they will judge him and they will
take him out because that's how the game
is played and if you remember in the
last go-around with this you remember
that moment where Bernie was on stage
and the black lives matter activists
grabbed the mic out of his hand and he
just moved over and stood there like a
little [ __ ]
[Laughter]
oh I'm okay on the language right we're
good yeah but but there's a reason he
did it he it wasn't because it was what
he believed he should do it was because
by the intersectional game that the
progressives have created he knew if he
grabbed the mic back at his own event
from black lives matter activists they
were gonna say he was racist and destroy
him so they are just buying their time
to take out Bernie at some point and
Elizabeth Warren will have to do it and
then I think it sets up you know then
then there's a woman running against
Trump I mean it just gets this all to
the the zenith of of lunacy let me ask
you about one of the things that kind of
I always see as a debate or a discussion
is the idea of educating or maybe
focusing more on some of the cultural
things versus the political arena I
think you coming through you know the
comedian side - Young Turks and
obviously those transformation and
having your own platform being a
personality do you think that you have
changed your mind on this do you think
that there is one because because my
take has always been that there's got to
be a balance right I think if you have a
core set of principles you know you go
out you engage folks you figure out ways
to connect with them whether it's
through culture whether it's through
education but then the political arena
has just been bidding the [ __ ] out of us
for the past 30 years so you can't
ignore that side do you agree with kind
of that take that there's a hybrid or do
you think we need to be a you know we're
failing in one section and we're gaining
in another what's kind of yours well as
I referenced earlier with MLK and
Malcolm X whatever whatever the movement
is whatever you care about is there's
many ways to skin a cat right and I
think you need people that can purely
deal with things at the idea level right
that can really lay out simple
principles so I try when I have somebody
like let's say jordan peterson on who's
talking about Nietzsche and Dostoevsky
and some seriously high-level stuff I
think one of the things I'm good at is
distilling some of that so that the
average person who maybe can't read all
of these things or take all of this in
can can digest it and hopefully find a
path where they can you know find out
more if that's what they want to do and
I think in in this political atmosphere
that we need
we need people to understand I think the
the basics of the founding of the
country of the principles of
individualism understand why the
Constitution was written why'd they
write it the way that they did what does
the Bill of Rights actually mean all of
these things you know understand why why
did they write regardless of your
feelings about religion why did they say
these were god-given rights and that it
wasn't the government that was giving
you those rights these are deeply
important things to understand but if
you're only gonna talk about that you're
not gonna get these guys and what what
does get these guys is comedy is memes
is all of is is shitposting I mean it's
all of those things so you need you need
some version of all of that and everyone
plays a little bit of a different role
in that so I think the important thing
this is what I would say about about
anything you should do what you think
you should do and and if you do that and
you're an idea guy and you do it well
you'll feck people and if you do that
and you're funny
you'll affect people in it and whatever
that means to you you got to hit it on
many fronts but this is where you know I
mean I always tell you it's like I love
coming to these yeah things because for
whatever little differences we have it's
utter I know none of you actually that
would never that would never cause an
irreparable problem for us like I know
you guys want to work through issues if
I had a difference of opinion we could
you know have a drink after talk it out
I mean we have some difference of
opinion and we can we can battle that
through and that's what I meant before
about just being a little bit better
than the other guys because they're
pretty hysterical right now and if we
just show oh you know what somebody's a
little more conservative on say abortion
than I am and I'm a little more hardcore
on low taxes or states rights than they
are but we basically want to live in the
same country well now we can start
expanding the tent and the progressives
are just purging people right that's
what they're doing they're taking good
decent liberals like me like Brent
Weinstein who I talked about before
or his brother Eric Weinstein plenty I
mean there's a zillion people Sam Harris
a million people there actually it's
many millions of decent liberals because
decent liberals do exist but they've
been cowed into silence so why not as
the progressives are purging all of
their free thinkers
and it's not even that they're purely
freethinkers they're just somebody that
might have one random other thought
while they're purging them why not have
the people especially on the Liberty
side of things really show yeah I'm
willing to agree to disagree and I want
to live in a country where my neighbor
can think something different that
sounds pretty great to me so I want to
talk about Jordan Peterson yes so many
you know you know Dave toured with
Jordan talking to I mean thousands
thousands of people and what fascinates
me about Jordan Peterson I cannot stop
watching the interview he did the one
that you know kind of went off where I
felt like every single time he would say
anything what's her name Kathy Newman
yeah Kathy Newman would say what you're
saying what you're saying is and she'd
fill in the blank and to hear Jordan who
at the time when I first watched this I
didn't know who he was I didn't know any
of his beliefs but to hear him say no
I'm not saying that at all right and
that was a pretty decent Peterson you
see how the voice kind of Fraga fide
there that was good but when he when he
would say that it resonated with so much
of not just what I've been through but
with so many of our student activists
when it's like you know anything you say
is just immediately paraphrased into
this horrific you know it just it's it's
just factually not correct so I guess my
question I have a few questions about
Peterson but I want to kind of open it
up to why do you think people reacted
the way they did let's let's not even
say I mean when the mob went after him
but just I mean it wasn't like they went
after I mean he just took off and with
you being on the road with them and you
kind of understanding him at a much
deeper level you know what what do you
think really sparked kind of this
Peterson mania of you know yeah I agree
with this guy and he's just saying
things I'm not used to hearing
yeah well I think you hit the nail on
the head related to the Kathy Newman
thing because so many of us we're
dealing with that all the time that
you're just trying to lay out a simple
perhaps hard truth and what you get in
exchange is you know so what you're
saying is or you're a bigot or a racist
the rest of it and there's a beautiful
moment in that where he says something
to the effect of well you don't mind
offending me
that wasn't so good all right you know
but his because he basically was saying
well you might be a saying to him you
might be offending trans people or
whatever and and his point was well you
don't mind offending me and but she had
as a lefty she has this hierarchical
category of who can be offended and all
that I think that moment took off
because of that because it was just a
simple example of keeping your cool
knowing what you're saying and then
really the moment where Kathy kind of
couldn't speak because you could see the
conflicting ideas that just sat in her
head all sort of colliding into each
other so she really couldn't get out of
it and and you know the funny part is
that right after that I wonder how many
of you guys know this within hours after
the clip started going viral she was
taking selfies and and doing a video I
think in her car with a co-worker
talking about all the trolls that were
coming after her but then once it really
caught on next thing you know she
started playing the victim and now you
know all she's getting death threats and
all these things and it's all not true
but she then realized the power of
playing the victim and all that instead
of actually going into a conversation
and knowing what you're talking about
enough to be able to have that
back-and-forth if you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlists all right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell